[Music]
give me liberty or give me death
let us fight for independence up until
our final breath the one regret that we
should all have in our mind we only have
one life to give up all the future of
mankind
april fools I'm just a jab how about we
give ourself a health care stick are
granted with the tap I'm talking penis
pills so you and your you april fools
they cookin is a fifteen four score and
seven years in the fan there was a
broader crowd I'd see you all but early
penguin ten thousand sacrifice their
lives upon this earth to ensure that a
free nation shall not perish from the
earth
April Fool playful please think I do we
could monitor your browser history and
use your phone to watch you number two
who's able to dig cookies
ask not talk about yourself as what you
can do for your country little [ __ ]
on the show may the Communists abroad
here this reprise we shall pay any cause
to ensure that Ximenes survive April
Fool just cheeky chance there's a
missile crisis yet this isn't happening
if you're so tasty free pilfer can China
I owe you
Oh April Fool's April Fool's April
Fool's April Fool's they die in vain
life is dangerous impaired people under
Harrison complain must we give thought
to the price paid by the Oh they
proposed a federal work force
small idli they blew is in Latin death
William Palpatine talking free stuff for
you what do you do when your what you
would you can you
[Music]